let's look at the winning painting jason
allen put in three a space
opera theater is actually a mesmerizing
work what it reminds me of very much of
the the paintings of a symbolist artist
uh gustav moreau who in fact had quite a
considerable influence on the
impressionists it's rather like
part game of thrones part
star wars a sort of part of faux
medieval tableau and also if you look at
the coloring there echoes and indeed uh
the artist mentions this that he was
inspired by leonardo so this is a thing
of beauty i think the problem is simply
the shock once artists get over that
they'll be able to adjust
[Music]
there is a human input needed into this
uh jason allen said that he put some 80
hours into it so that is i think very
important to stress the other thing is
that obviously when there are new
movements in art and i mean one could
choose either the impressionists or the
cubists or the surrealists i mean it
always disturbs and shocks a few people
or sometimes a very large number of
people it's one of art's purposes
you